myself Mars and shore dog all day I'm
gonna break down in a minute
yeah why call me underground when I rock
the Stars didn't even think you see me
with a pleura blind knock your laws my
hip-hop and gave a good sideswipe to
Mars pump turbine extinction hitless
left the limelight a jaw you won't just
rips to fly not in my solar system cuz I
dismiss them like they wish to die like
mother nature and I wish the why but
Lillian ladies love me so brooch user
why she's kissed the Scout yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you want your scripts to fly not in my
solar system because I dismiss him like
they wished it down like mother nature
when I rip the why civilians ladies love
me supports user washi kiss this guy
call me master more exalted than the
priest or pastor blasphemy have me glass
wax fast with magma in the air like
dancing Dasha
high in the sky above about lives up in
Alaska I got the million and woman hits
a pizza last year cheaper Celestia when
everyone stepped off in the pasture the
lacquer will castor down below those who
get caught and my raptured don't be
calling me dog cuz I won't have to say
it backwards but uh but uh aren't you
going
so guy here really yeah every night
seemed like it was celebrating birthdays
cuz rapping on planet Earth space
smelling like birthdays or was a facade
you got me sloppy from fluffing these
parties and shots of sake copy are you
ladies in here I am Sharon Ward I just
wanna lay between you and Rams grantor
trust me when it come to women your man
errands good I've been inside of more
women than Planned Parenthood I got no
bottles the newborn babies for you
pouring ladies I want you to drink up to
you horn crazy and rape me till I'm lazy
and achy when I get shady and take me
okay baby let's say we take me insane
too tricky
I'm just partying I ain't letting the
tool spit I'm there trying to have your
head is bland below the pool 20 acres of
them you'll sit in my garage with a tool
kit what did I tell on a [ __ ] if he
plans to take my riches I never talk to
[ __ ] then till this time the [ __ ] I'm
on the microphone and I don't want to
get stuck and I check it out I got to do
a radio version Murch the most perverted
[ __ ] kicking that perversion now
you can use a diversion to try to direct
your attention away from the cuss words
but when I flush bird's ass always
which is when I've given you a way to
live I did the microphone cuz it's my
prerogative I'll take you I'll break it
down make this simple I'll rap over
anybody's instrumental now this your
Saigon why on earth would you try mercy
this is Earth Day and I would like to
give birth to ways to recycle min and
making green energy because I like to
make green because then that makes
enemies because they hate all types of
photos try to come and try to steal my
relish throw my tomatoes but I tell them
later I'm pulling them up like play-doh
cuz I'm old my own destiny you testing
me you must be insane I'm off the brain
off the top of the dome I do this I make
it rain verbs and agitators I call me do
it like this I had to give all I could
this ever since I was little winner
heard they said you would make it I
shoot I'm dropping off but never
stopping off I might stop to coffee then
spit a loogie but you cannot with me
I'm trying to do it like this and I love
fiddly and Rick Ross but come on man the
kids cause when my stuff is played next
to it I get respect and I will educate
those that need to be directed to the
truth it's tec-9 cut Calhoun and Chris
calico all up in the booth with Merce
and urs the first dude to hear you
picking cursed on the radio because I
never cared they don't play me anyway so
here we go again bootleg care of Atlanta
sees them on my friends I represent for
the sixth row all the way down through
Tucson and you know that's my cool stand
without killing my brother rise there
you got different faces he faced the
five cases but we will all erase it I
got five grand
Ryan Donovan let me not get personal
yeah curly cow bloody curly may we wear
finale to infinity and when you mention
tec-9 your best of mention that mother
in Trinity cut Calhoun the Calico called
me cut the creature in creation and the
feature presentation is live and
directed my style is one on one hit the
freestyle up the dome for one no one
wild point one and it's live and direct
denied a hole looking for that potato to
reject my semen in but the condoms
aren't so you gets no love for me [ __ ]
be gone looks like us I mean it should
be gone it's all crazy I'm hazy I'm in
another thing I'm from KC killer City
killer clown is in the building
getting down up in the building we don't
brown one in the building cuz we given
what they want and we giving them what
they need you see me y'all up on the
stage you wish you could get with me and
you can get with me 15:36 3 836 [ __ ]
that's all good and I'm just messing
around I'm just messing around
oh no gala go get on the world man no
order another drink I don't care what
you think I'm getting drunk as a skunk
and throw up in the sink it's a
celebration [ __ ]
bottoms up break the ditches thick and
delicious book my birthday wishes sober
dually one or two I'll be stupid you mix
up a picture whatever abbulu I'm
thinking it's a pa rt why cuz I got
ain't leavin chill and out my bottle
grab another round before last call not
for the clowns talkin loud but got a
glass jaw I'm so totally like my eyes
just about to blast off slow motion I
can hear your dead flesh hub slow it
down
baby and get a handle on it I'll be your
birthday cake blow out the candle onna
and I want it cause it's pretty Yonkers
around we won't stop until they close
this place down happy birthday everybody